this guy's security and defense analyst
Michael Clarke joins me now Professor
Clark great great see you as always
let's touch on the on the bombing uh in
zapparesia uh recently was that likely a
direct retaliation to the uh the issue
on the Crimea Bridge yes it's hard to
see that it isn't uh it's the most
immediate thing that Mr Putin could do
they've been bombings operation with or
lobbing missiles as I please have three
or four nights no more last night and
they fall on civilian areas so repairing
the bridge and and uh causing more
civilian casualties is all that they can
do at the moment but Putin is under
pressure as a lot of the Russian media
is extremely angry about this and you
know you can see that there are reports
um in the Washington Post that President
Biden was briefed this week on internal
dissent inside the Kremlin so he's under
pressure to do something and this is the
sort of thing that he responds with
certainly in the short term let's touch
on the attack on uh or the explosion on
the bridge to Crimea uh talk through us
the the significance of that explosion
both logistically for Russia and
symbolically yeah it's a good question
wolf because it's all about range I mean
there's been three big attacks in Crimea
in the last couple of months so the the
attack on saki air base on the zankoy uh
ammunition base
here the zanko ammunition Center here
and the Kirsch bridge and they're all
out of range of the artillery that we
know the ukrainians have got so the
question is how are they doing it now
obviously there's some special forces
involved here but it's unlikely that
these were all sabotaged bringing
explosives only with special forces it
seems possible that there were some
missiles involved
the ukrainians we don't are not supposed
to have the J takims but it looks as if
they may well have because the J
tackham's missile it's uh it's a missile
that can go 180 miles it is within range
if they fire it within the their areas
there's your jtakams it looks a bit like
a an old Moon rocket and but it can be
fired from a multiple launch rocket
system and normally those systems take
either 6 or 12 smaller missiles you can
replace the Pod with just one that takes
one of those and that has the sort of
Warhead a 500 pound Warhead that would
do the sort of damage that we've seen in
those areas of Crimea so if we're we're
all asking the question how are they
doing it and they're not going to tell
us because they might want to do it
again but it seems to be a a mixture of
sabotage and special forces and possibly
J tackham's missiles which they may have
got not directly from America but maybe
from Romania and Poland or even turkey
who America has supplied with these
weapons quite recently and so what does
this mean for the the weeks and months
ahead if they do have this sort of
capabilities does it alter what's likely
to come next yeah it's interesting
because I mean these these May these are
symbolic hits no doubt and they they
complicate Russia's Logistics to Kirsten
but but we're wondering the analytical
Community out there is thinking is this
softening up Russian Logistics or
something else I mean the ukrainians are
attacking in in Donuts so they're moving
into luhanskin they're trying to take
back the donbass they're doing very well
in cursing they may well take person in
the next few weeks I mean they've got
two big attacks going on which are
successful they have reserves we know
they have reserves
um something like three brigades worth
ready to go it seems and how will they
use them that's the question we're all
asking ourselves is it possible this is
just speculation but is it possible that
they might go south from zaponesia and
try and open up a new Corridor to
militar split this land bridge in into
if they do that before the winter then
the Russians really will be on the run
as far as these operations are concerned
that doesn't end the war but my goodness
the Ukrainian if that were the case
would go into the winter as it were
hugely ahead on the ground in this
particular
Warfare situation Professor Clark as
always thanks so much